each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it is my pleasure to a welcome Jin Ling
Lee as the speaker of this presentation
Jin Ling is from Georgia Tech and this
summer he is supervised by DNA followed
firenzi oh and me on the project of
client-side echo cancellation for
multiparty audio conferencing so here's
her journaling hi Thank You introduction
good afternoon everyone the topic of my
talk is client-side echo cancellation
for multiparty audio conferencing this
is my summer internship project with
delay and the leeway from ccs group
the outline of my talk is first I will
talk about the popular multi-party audio
conferencing architecture then introduce
Chris thats related turn off the speaker
mic
or you can continue okay first I will
talk about some popular multi-party
audio conferencing architecture and then
introduce a new architecture which
potentially will reduce the bandwidth es
and the computation requirement which
will reduce the computation and radius
and computing computation requirement
but this architecture will introduce the
echo so how to remove this echo is a
major task of this talk then we will
present some subjective test and results
and they talk about the practical issues
and the concluded a stalk the first
architecture we talk about is formation
structure in this structure any two of
the client will direct any communication
with each other the advantage of this of
this structure is higher audio quality
nest dinnae because this is a tandem
free structure only one encoding and
decoding involve the disadvantage of
this architecture is hype and of a
description and the computation load
after and the point for example this
little structure this figure each client
needs through a upload and download the
band of a DS and the slowest decoding so
to reduce the bandwidth es and the
computation at the end the point msu
paste the structure is introduced the
diagram as this there has three active
speaker and one listener each speaker
Center his speech 2 m's you and the msu
generate a mixed speech specific mix the
speech for each for each client such as
for a the nco will mix say and addy and
a sender to a so the advantage of this
architecture for the point only one
upload
download the band vedas and one decoding
is readable but the problem of this
architecture is the band vedas and the
computations requirement at the msu is
very high in this example slow a
download for upload the band varies
slightly coding for mixing and the for
encoding is needed offense you so reduce
to reduce the bandwidth and the
computation requirement events you we
introduce a new nc-based structure
similar ways before every client is in
the his speech cleanse you but ms you
will generate our common mixes VG and
send it to everyone which include all
the speech from every client so in this
structure sim with the traditional
nc-based the structure only one upload
the download and the one decoding is
needed at the end point also a dilemma
see you because msu will send our common
and single to every client so
potentially broadcast can be used if
broadcast use the upload the panda
ladies only one upload another advantage
of this structure is ms you only needed
two to one mixing and one encoding so
the band of a DS and the computation
requirement at msu posts will be reduced
but the problem of this structure is the
download of speech include all the
speech from everybody so the windsor
client received as a download stream
he'll either remove himself speech first
before playback this is our echo so this
you introduce the client-side echo
cancellation problem this is a major
work of this let's talk this table
briefly compare these three structures
as we procure before the proposed the
ends you based a strong
sure greatly reduce the band of 80s and
the computation requirement both are the
endpoint and the MSU if broadcast used
another point about machines for the
traditional MSU based structure is
relying on a venerable voice activity
detection or speaker selection algorithm
to reduce the bandwidth and the
computation attends you but a further
probe has proposed the MCU based the
structure since the only one upload you
fro the cost used and one mix in one
encoding whatever how many active
speakers so we may relax the voice
activity detection operates so how to
implement the proposed MCU basis
architecture this is a diagram each
client is in his speech to msu the blue
box is msu msu first decode other speech
and mix together and the encode and then
send it to every client the red box is
one of the client up before after
decoding the download stream before
playback haley to remove himself so this
yellow box is a major part of this work
before we talk about how to remove this
echo refers to look at the Kentucky the
self in this system we use the activity
g dot 7 22 10 to clock the input audio
first goes through MLT transform the MLG
transform is a modified the PCT
transform the MLT coefficients cody the
region by region each ready include the
20 coefficients and the totally 14
regions for each frame
for two for each region the region power
will be quantized computer quantizer
than a coding then the MLT crayfishes
coefficients will be normalized apply
the quantized the region power and then
the long lines the emirate equation will
be skynyrd quantized the contacts step
size is decided by this category
information this information is decided
by raging power the power of each
regions so totally there has eight
categories as shown in this table
different the category has different
quantization step size so before we talk
about the our proposed the measure we
first look at the three simple solutions
this is a most lately solution just
directly subtract to the original speech
hi it's gantu runs well this open the
crate glass so by this lady solution a
lot of food ecole demain this is another
simple solution we subtracted a single
right before this mixing so this a
single oh we subtract to this single
pipes can to rust weln is open the crate
but don't break the glass compare is
saluting one the echo reduced but still
has a lot of echo this is another simple
solution so the basic idea are here we
try to simulate as a the same process
the echo goes through encoding decoding
and encoding decoding so before
subtraction we also make this original
speech goes through to encoding and
decoding under then subtract gantu rust
wellness open the crate but don't break
the glass okay nor still has some echo
remain so the problem is this encoder
under this encoder not exactly the same
thing the quantization parameters in
this two encoder is different because as
we mentioned before the parameter the
quantization parameter in the encoder is
depends on the input speech for this
encoder the input speech is a plus B and
here the encoder speech is a so this
will make the quantization parameter in
this two encoder is different so this
also trigger all refers to propose the
measure
so to make this to make this to encoder
exactly the same thing whether you
enforce the quantization parameters used
in this encoder is same way since this
encoder since the quantization
parameters used in this encoder all the
quantization hydrometers also embedded
in this stream so that decoder can be
can recover all the quantization
parameters so this encoder leading the
code to this encoder get a parameter
they can change the parameter directly
from this decoder this decoder is also
use a client side so there has low
additional cost began to rust well new
open the crate but don't break the glass
so from this speech we can tell two
things first as the echo is gone we move
to the echo an RC is there has some
effects in the speech so how this happen
we take a quick look mathematically
where humans of quantization step is
caress and the a contest with ka plus
some quantization error OE a big contest
with KP with some candidates arrow EP so
after some simple maths we get these
final results so the the final
distorting for P is necklace this
equation tells the two sensors first the
distorting include the last thing about
a so this is a reason why the echo come
there is no a in the final results
another thing is sometimes their way
there may have a big distortion such as
when EP is very small under the
quantization step is very big this is
torching
very big so mostly the artifacts from
here this one this one yeah because when
here we really the Unicode the a plus B
for cancer right this means here we
assume we individually encode a and B
with this encoder so a and B Royal
quantized to the next days so when we
quantize a plus B the output we like
this ka plus KP times quest and the
these two arrow we also will be
contacted if this to arrow the sum of
this way so is not your than half of the
quantization steps there will be another
the quantize the output will not equal
to k plus KP so from this equation way
we get the two conclusions as we said
there has nothing about a solo echo and
the distorting may be very naughty
sometimes so this is a reason there has
some artifacts so to remove the echo and
at the same time we try to reduce the
artifacts we propose the another
solution illness in the prover solution
we always try to simulate the same
process the echo goes through by to
encode the decode encoder decoder under
then subtract the echo from the next
speech at here we don't explicitly
subtract the echo we directly estimate
as a desire of speech p by kevins is
quantized a plus B and this itself
so mathematically this problem can be
formulated as we're given contest a plus
B and a to estimate be if we assume with
the PDF function of B is FB and the best
estimation for P to minimize the mean
square error is a condition mean this is
a very low including so essentially
these two condition tell us the possible
region for P and the way the PDF
focusing of B we can easily get the best
estimation about p butter here will
either too low the PDF function of B
this is unknown we need to estimate this
so we assume all the 20 MLT coefficients
in the same region is independent
identical Gaussian distribution with 0
mean and the variance Sigma square then
the problem tends to estimate this
variance Sigma square this can be
estimated necklace so in summary we want
to we want pelos SP so we needed low FB
to get FB really does SP so essentially
we can solve this problem by jointly
solve the two equations of course the
first equation this equation include the
20 component because this p and a the 20
dimension vector so here we use use a
iterative procedure to estimate this
beyond the sigma square first initialize
the p this justin results of the
proposal major one and then iteratively
estimate the sigma square and Abby but
there are has a special case for P if P
is small enough such as in such data
context the a plus B is equal to 1 x 2 a
then we make this be 0 to avoid some
later to echoes so this is a results the
pipe began to rust well new open the
crate but don't break the glass so
compare ways of it the results from
solution one pipe began to rest well new
open the crate but don't break the glass
so we can see the results of solution
one has some effects but lots of
solution be greatly reduced the
artifacts the witnesses are still has
some artifacts but greatly reduced and
this is a spectrogram of this to output
speech and in in this in this figure we
can see there has some isolated a bigger
coefficients of X is this and there has
something like this mostly the artifacts
is from this kind of place but with the
proposed the measure P this kind of
isolated the coefficient greatly reduced
and the artifacts also greatly reduced
next we try to further improve the
performance of this this matter here
waiting should introduce another
function adaptable noise feeling after
echo cancellation voice feeling is also
a component in the original g37 22,000
Katoch but but the original noise feel
or ism is based on the use for the
quantized the singular self-repair we
want to fear laws for the single signal
after this echo cancellation so the
original Louis feel algorithm may not
directly applied in our
case before we look discuss our proposed
alloys feel algorithm we first look at
the original moist few upgrades as we
already see this is a g37 22,000 or the
clock and the for this scalar
quantization there has a category
information to decide the quantization
steps totally there has eight categories
with a large category the quantization
steps is also large so for this kind of
large not category the quantization
steps you too large make many
coefficients quantizer 20 this is the
reason why we need to feel some noise to
fill voids really the answer to
questions where to fill voids and how
much lloyds to fill as we already
mentioned in the original G Delta 722
thought one to talk the lowest fear will
be for category seven because there has
low any transmission no coding another
is for category five and six because the
quantization step is to two large make
many coefficients fantastic 20 so we
need to feel some noise so about how
much noise to fail is based on the
quantization step size because the 0
coefficient is because there has a big
of quantization step for our proposed
the noise feel awkward we still need to
answer these two questions where to fair
Lloyd's under how much Lloyd's to fill
butter answer for this to question may
different with the original noise field
for a first question where to fill voice
to answer this question really the true
too low how the quantization steps
related with the desired of speech
because we want to fail laws for the
design of speech not a lot quantize the
mixed speech itself
if the desired a speech in the previous
figure that is that which means the PE
singular if the design of speech is a
dominant in the region compared with the
echo species that means the conjugation
steps is mainly depends on this desired
a speech so the same noise fierce game
can be used that here that means we feel
low is for category five six and seven
if the desired speech is a comparable
with the echo speech so in this case the
quantization steps is a little we can
imagine is a little bigger than the
undulation steps of for the design of
speech itself button not too big so we
expended this nice field to pull more
category that means from three to seven
if the echo speech is prominently in
this region that means the Geezer speech
is very small and the quantization steps
in a much bigger than the desired speech
in this case we realize for every region
the galleries the quantization category
the other question for how much noise to
how much noise to fill in the original
algorithm the noise depends on the
undulation steps but here the lowest is
not only depends on the quantization
steps also depends on the quantized
energy of the desired a single yourself
not the mixed single or so the lowest
field exist is a minimum of f 1 and f 2
f 1 is a is a function of quantization
step is seen with the original g37
22,000 katoch and f2 is a needing
function of the energy of the desired of
speech this
this can be computed from the estimator
MLT coefficient because we also we
already get the energy equation for P
and for some special case if this
quantized the this quantized energy is 0
we may need some interpolation from the
time domain and the frequency domain
Labour's ok theory the results play
again to rust well new open the crate
but don't break the glass compare with
the result Louis feeling case the pipe
began to rust well new open the crate
but don't break the glass you may come
to tell the difference but we claim
there has with the noise feel the
artifacts slightly reduced ok let's go
back from this user spectrogram from
this a spectrogram we also can see
something such a next Nexus kind of four
regions with some noise feel make this
this isolated a coefficient not isolated
anymore so makes this more smooth like
so let's talk about is a subjective
subject with has great deal to evaluate
as a performance of the proposed occurs
we use a category absolute category
rating with being up in school this is a
standard has to be complete by a cutie
the test data used is from 0 for person
audio conference and the to simulate is
a real communication system and the
masking effective the test of file
generated
exists for each client we generate our
stereo file the original speech of the
client is put in the left channel and
persist the speech of all the other
client with 200 milliseconds of delay
put in a right channel so in this
setting we try to simulate the masking
effect ok this is a pestle results we
test the three measures the simple
measure to we mention the people and the
proposed mater one in the middle 2 & a
compared with the traditional MCO based
measure and another extreme case result
of any Cody so this is a most school the
difference between our proposed measure
with the traditional MSU based measure
is about two pointer to Drew has some
sample maybe you can cream
three times um yeah right and I would go
there dance or claim okay enough to
channel the user to listen to the right
channel away I've raid raid the right
channel yeah so we assume that the left
channel is the audio that's present in
the local site so from here you may get
in here on some echoes because for a
year for this is the pesto sentence
there has a no machi concurrent or
speaker every speaker kind of speaker at
a different time so you as a previous
results we say this mirror will have a
lot of remaining echoes I've been there
three times Wow so listen um yeah right
and I would go there again certainly
okay I've been there three times Wow
Solverson um yeah right and I would go
there again certainly okay I've been
there three times Wow Solverson um yeah
right and I would go there again
certainly okay I've been there three
times Wow so obviously um yeah people
right and I would go there again
certainly okay so from this this files
we can we can see the results of a
proposed the mirror two is similar ways
though traditionally based measures
there's has another example way to go oh
did you have to pick three places yeah
whatever the reason is the first one hey
Greg if you listen very carefully there
there hi son echo
would go all did you have to pick three
places yeah whatever you don this the
first one hey Greg we all did he have to
pick three places yeah whatever the
reason is the first one hey Greg whoo oh
did you have to pick three places yeah
whatever your breath on this is the
first one hey Greg oh did you have to
pick three places yeah whatever you don
this is the first one hey Greg under
actually those results between these two
mmm the zealots of this measure has much
less at facts than this mirror since we
can't pay very clearly from this this
file but if you listen maybe some it's
not loud enough or something and this
table show a detailed results for people
in the coatings rate 16 kilobytes 2432
the basic employees is seen with here
the traditional msu based measure is the
best and this is a proposed measure tool
and this is a better one and this is the
simple measure but there are some
something unexpected at this point such
as a 44 proposed the better to add 32
kilo bits the mostest ago even smaller
than this 16 kilo bits and a 24 and for
the traditional means you based a
measure that 24k repeats it worse than
16 because this is this something we
don't expected the possible reason for
this one reason is maybe is a testing
data is a
not many enough right away in the
database will include the force sentence
for different measure in four different
sentence under 30 30 people listen to
the results around one because we have
only discrete choices yeah okay the
it's all integer numbers so one one one
possible reason is the test data is not
many enough only for sentencing cluded
in the database and the only 30 person
to the test a trailer for each person
only test half of the data only listen
to half of the data so we we are still
waiting for more tests or to this test
and another reason I i can say maybe
because of the this species from the
real communication and there has many
background noise especially for this
right channel hey mix slowly different
persons so the background noise will add
together and when the background noise
is too big maybe the difference between
differences wait not very clear this is
the results of cotton stage okay next we
talk about the pride practically issues
because to make this sis system the
early practic we need to consider
packaging not package Jeter and the
packet loss traditionally for package
eater auto header is used to stretch
your compress the speech from different
client and the packet loss may happen on
the upload link from client to MCU
although download link from MCU to
client to handle the packet loss
normally package and most concealment
upgrades will be used the decoder which
can work on the time domain or the
frequency domain but here one more
problem is the package eater and the
packet loss both will impact on the
client side the echo cancellation this
is a solution tentatively solution for
each client center his speedy 2m see you
in this link make a packet loss or some
delay jitter so in the MCU the packet
loss consume
and the other cleaner will work here to
handle the packet loss and ajit jitter
so after the client side before echo
cancellation we also lead to the same
thing for this to the same scene the MCU
to to make this single and the cycler
and this signal is a sim exactly seem so
they're here we need to sunset
information from MCU we need to some
information about ends you how to this
tightness concealment or what or you can
or to Tuesday's speech if himself would
even a lost or didn't have Jeter so
there has nothing to do but he ends you
do something for this client speech at
the client-side Ranger to the same scene
p for echo cancellation and another if
the info packet loss on the download
link from the MCU through the client so
the package not consuming the way down
here we do this packet loss consume and
after echo cancellation not on this side
didn't do this packet loss consume it on
the download speed mix the speech we do
this on the echo cancellation the speech
also the pectin us consuming the can be
done in time domain or frequency domain
so to conclude my talk in this summer we
first introduced a new multi-party audio
conference in structure this structure
potentially you can reduce the bandwidth
and the computation requirements at
posts and the point under the msu to
make this structure exactly work we
propose a client-side echo cancellation
operation as the future work week women
handle the echo packet loss and a jitter
together to make the whole system
practic another interesting topic is the
expansion the proposed the client-side
the echo cancellation algorithm four
different speech
audio codec maybe kalpa base the kodak
or something else this is the end of my
talk thanks for coming